لا أستطيع الذهاب إلى تركيا دون التحدث عن
المفروشات والسجاد ،
آه ، مرحباً ،
كيف حالك جيد لمقابلتك ،
هذه روث لوكوود
، متذوق السجاد من نيوزيلندا
التي أتت إلى تركيا منذ
أكثر من 30 عامًا ، أعني عندما
أتيت إلى هنا لأول مرة
كان الأمر شبيهاً بالخشب الخشبي
للسجاد
وسيظل الناس يقولون لي ، أوه ،
لم تكن هنا ، ثم أين أنت
حيث يجلب التجار بضاعتهم ،
أعطتني روث دورة تدريبية
مكثفة في اختيار السجادة المثالية
كم مرة تمر بهذا  يمكن أن تفعل
هذا أربع مرات في
اليوم ، والشيء هو أنهم سيقدمون لك
أشياء لا تحبها
وسيقدمون لك أشياء جديدة لا
تريدها وأنت تأمل دائمًا أن تجد أن
اليابان
لا تلعب  لعبة البوكر مع روث هي
لا تعطي إيماءة إيماءة ، ولكن تم رمي
قطع العين المغلقة جانبًا ،
فمن الواضح أن الحقيقة هي بعد الجودة وليس
الكمية ، روث هو ساحر السجاد
وأنا متدرب الساحر.
يمكن أن يشعر بالجودة ليس ذلك
أنا أعرف أي شيء إذا كنت أتحدث عن
روث وينتز تخبرني أنني قد ارتكبت خطأ
تلميذ
في البداية بحماسي الصبياني ،
لقد رفعت السعر بالنسبة لي ، فمن
الأفضل دائمًا ألا تبدو متحمسًا جدًا
عند الشراء
لأنه  أنت تعلم أنهم حصلوا على فكرة
أنك تحبها وبالطبع
السعر سيرتفع
آسف
لا ليس مثل ذلك لن يبيع
السجاد أبدًا هناك أكثر من مجرد
التدوير والتعامل مع
هذه الهويات المنسوجة من خيوط
التاريخ إذا كنت تريد
كل  منطقة ، كل قرية ، كل قبيلة
لها أحجام وألوان وتصميمات
تنتمي
إلى تلك المجموعة ، هذه القطعة المعينة يبلغ
عمرها حوالي 90 عامًا ، هذه القطعة
قديمة ،
تقول قديمة ، فهذا يعني
أنه تم استخدامها ، فأنت تعلم أن
بائع السيارات الذي تستخدمه عبر الإنترنت  سيدة مبيعات سجاد مستعملة ،
يا أيها الرجل الشقي الذي تبيعه سجادًا مستعملًا
جيدًا ، كنت أنظر إلى أنفي
قليلاً وأقول لا ، إنهم ليسوا
مستعملة ، إنها عتيقة جميلة ، إنها قديمة
وتمثل تاريخًا  و أ
تقليد لا يمكننا العودة
إليك